[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres des
herrn für den ramadan
entweder könnte des abends nach dem
fastenbrechen essen oder erhebt euch
auch für das ramadanfest und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier heute einen lauf würde
also ein berg aber es ist was süßes und
es erinnert ein bisschen an galactica an
das griechische dessert und es hat auch
geografisch und historisch gesehen auch
wirklich etwas miteinander zu tun
wer meine freundin ließ kriechen die fdf
dogs und sie ist eigentlich auch lars
also das ist damals aus dem osmanischen
reich und anatolien ist jetzt ziemlich
lange geschichte jedenfalls entstand
daraus dieses leckere desserts
ich habe jetzt hier eine art parcours
war aber mit einem richtig leckeren
vanillepudding in der mitte man kann das
ganze mit sirup trinken oder macht so
wie ich mit produktion ist ein bisschen
leichtere variante und ziemlich lecker
entweder könnte jetzt die backware
blätter selber zubereiten oder auch
fertige kaufen dann geht es nämlich noch
schneller
ich zeige euch jetzt aber mal die selbst
gemachter variante und zeigt euch die
zutaten für den teig für den teig
verwende ich 150 gramm sie naturjoghurt
120 gramm sonnenblumenöl 100 gramm
wasser ein eine prise salz 25 gramm
weiche butter und 600 gramm mehl nämlich
erst die flüssigen zutaten also dazu
zählt für mich jetzt auch der joghurt
das ist ein naturjoghurt denn nicht
gelöst ist findet man echt oft noch ganz
schwer in den meisten joghurt sorten
steckt nämlich echt zucker drin aber es
ein naturjoghurt ohne ohne zu kommen
doch dann das etwas wahr sagt
das gebe ich noch salz dazu und das kurz
verrühren
hier gebe ich jetzt nach und nach etwas
mehl dazu und sobald der teig etwas
fester wird auch die butter und dann
wechsle ich später einfach das relais
mend von diesem flach haken zum
knethaken weil es einfach im festen teig
wird
[Musik]
als die mutter rein ihr könnt den teig
natürlich auch mit den händen verkneten
meine mama macht es auch so oder habt
ihr immer so gemacht und hat dann
einfach immer nach wonach das mehl
dazugeben und dann sieht man auch wie
fester teig wird aber so geht's halt
nicht so einfach
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt aus als er ist
das ist ein relativ fest dort aber
dennoch geschmeidig in form ich jetzt
einfach kurz zu einer kugel und bei
bagdad gibt es ganz viele verschiedene
teile der herr ist jetzt mit joghurt ich
habe auch schon mal einen ohne joghurt
gemacht er war dann etwas fester und der
herr wird etwas her etwas geschmeidiger
deshalb darf jetzt ruhen für etwa eine
halbe stunde
dafür nehme ich ein sauberes geschirr
tuch das ist leicht feucht gemacht hier
jetzt einloggen so spart man sich die
frau holle folie und einfach kurz bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen für eine
halbe stunde
und ich kann in der zeit schon mal im
pudding vorbereiten den pudding verwende
ich 800 gramm mensch etwas vanille
extrakt 50 gramm zucker 70 stärke 1
eigelb und 20 gramm butter
ich gebe ich einfach ein bisschen milch
hier in den top dann kommt das eigelb
dazu das sorgt für eine schöne farbe ihr
könnt das eigelb auch weglassen nehmt
einfach 15 gramm mehr stärke aber ich
finde mit eigelb wird der pudding immer
etwas cremiger und bekommt eben diese
tolle vanille fahre dann etwas stärker
mit schirmchen frei verführen
dann den zucker mit rein und natürlich
wird in waldeck geschmack kommen der
extrakt
das ist nämlich hier die restliche milch
dazu und lasst den pudding während ich
höre schön aufkochen stellt den herd
immer gerne auf mittel hoher hitze so
bringt auch nicht sagen
[Musik]
putting ist jetzt fest und normalerweise
ist er schon bisschen frei aber es kann
ja sein dass die strecke küchen gebildet
hat also streiche ich ihnen noch einmal
durch ein feines haar sie entweder mit
dem schneebesen oder hier mit dem
fleißigen lieschen
[Musik]
jetzt noch die butter einrühren
die macht bislich geschmeidiger und wenn
ihr einen richtig schönen gelben pudding
haben wollt dann könnt ihr entweder 3g
übernehmen damit er richtig schön vor
allem auf diese menge oder ihr nehmt
einfach eine prise kurkuma kurkuma fährt
nämlich den pudding auch ganz natürlich
auch wirklich nur ganz wenig denn
kurkuma ist ziemlich intensiv
ihr seht es nur ein ganz kleines
bisschen und da war jede police jetzt
richtig natürlich war nämlich aus den
denke ich jetzt mit frischhaltefolie
habe damit keine haut bildet lassen kurz
abkühlen und dann rolle ich im prinzip
auch gleich schon den teig aus
kenne ich den teig ausrollen und
michaels hierfür 11 stärker mit mehl
damit lässt sich der teig nämlich super
aus rolle einfach kurz vermischen dann
den teig nehmen
und jetzt einfach etwa 40 portionen ein
teil denn der baccumer teig wird richtig
drin und wenn ich den teig nicht selber
machen wollt könnt ihr auch viele
teilnehmen oder baccara pack aus dem
türkischen supermarkt das geht auch aber
ich zeige euch heute hier wie es eben
komplett von null auf sechs gemacht wird
[Musik]
die hälfte es dann etwa 500 durch zehn
und 50 2 sind 25
warum es gut geschätzt ja und dann freue
mich einfach kleine kugeln und setzte
hier erst mal hin
[Musik]
alle fertig alle 40 und jetzt einfach
dieses mail stärke gemisch nehmen und
wirklich viel davon verwenden wenn
jemand eines erste weil es ja dann schon
wieder ausgeruht ist und sich leicht
ausrollen lässt jetzt wirklich schön
darin wälzen und dann erstmal mit einem
aus holz starb ausrollen
das reicht schon gar nicht so anstrengen
dann mache ich da wieder stärke
drauflegt zur seite und legt dann das
andere einfach oben drauf und gleich
machen wir die richtig dünn mit einem
rucksack mit meinem türkischen ausruhen
starb aber ich zeige euch was ihr nehmen
könnt wenn ihr kind gehabt
[Musik]
beim ausrollen und achte ich einfach
immer nur drauf ich drückte am anfang
kurz flach und dann antreten wenn es
immer und sie ist immer einmal durch
diese stärke gemisch damit die
geschichten einfach nicht zusammen geben
also stimmt einfach dafür dass es nicht
zusammengelebt und wenn ihr später was
übrig habt ich möchte jetzt auch gleich
noch was zusammen dann könnte das ja
einfach für den nächsten kuchen benutzen
einfach stärke und mehl rein und fertig
als ich keine verschwendung sondern ihr
braucht es wirklich um es richtig gut
aus rollen zu können
jetzt nimmt er einen großen auswahl
starb oder ein ob novartis gibt es im
türkischen supermarkt ich habe jetzt
mein opa war noch ehrlich sagt in der
alten wohnung vergessen auf dem
kühlschrank ist mir eingefallen
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier einfach und
besenstiel genug einen sauberen
zurechtgeschnitten und er ist sogar
schon geölt das heißt es passt perfekt
jetzt habt ihr immer diese fünf tage
schichten übereinander und immer schön
stärke gemischt dazwischen
jetzt werden die zusammen ausgeholt und
so klappt es wirklich wunderbar geht
ganz schnell
aber ganz wichtig wie gesagt dafür nicht
zusammenkleben sondern rolle ich das
immer hier gerne auf und dann mit ganz
viel gefühl von der mitte nach außen
streichen
so vergrößern sich die teigfladen
[Musik]
da ein bisschen abklopfen danach die
küche sorgen
guckt mal richtig dünn da muss man echt
aufpassen
die reisen auch schnell aber das ist
auch
[Musik]
die hälfte ist ausgerollt jetzt nämlich
in den ofen feste form mich da gerne im
iphone
da kommt jetzt flüssige butter rein
jetzt kommen hier die ersten 20
schichten rein und dazwischen kommt
einfach immer ein bisschen butter damit
später schön plaetrich wird so ein
bisschen einfach in falten legen bisher
butter drauf nächste schicht und so
einfach die form füllen
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt hier den abgekühlten
pudding dann ruhig noch mal kurz durch
und dann gleichmäßig darüber teil dass
wir dann praktisch wie pudding schicht
in der mitte
[Musik]
und hier kommen jetzt die restlichen 20
schichten obendrauf natürlich auch mit
butter dazwischen wenn eine größere
formen nimmt als ich dann wird es ganz
ein bisschen flacher und eben dünne
könnte ja auch machen ist auch wirklich
gut so wird es einfach ein bisschen
höher also das müsst ihr selber
entscheiden je nachdem wie groß eben
auch die portionen sein sollen
auf die letzte schicht einfach noch ein
bisschen rest butter bestreichen und
dann nehme ich jetzt gleich ein ganz
scharfes messer und wird schon mal vor
positionieren das macht mir immer vor
dem backen denn nach dem backen ist das
am anfang so kross das ist dann bricht
das heißt immer schön am anfang vor dem
backen schneiden macht man beim akt aber
auch so mag man schneidet man ganz gerne
in rauten zu ich schneide dieses der
selbst aber die kuchenstücke das gefällt
mir am besten
so sieht das dessert jetzt aus jetzt
kommt sie den backofen und darf langsam
und lange gebacken werden bis es schön
groß ist
so fertig gebacken und richtig schön
knusprig und jetzt bestreut noch warm
mit etwas butter zucker und zimt
das ist dann abkühlen
dann können wir schon verlieren man kann
es im prinzip auch mit zuckersirup
trinken so wie man es auch oft bei big
brother macht von anderen süßspeisen ich
finde hier kann man es aber auch
wirklich ohne die tränke lassen ich
werde dann nämlich lieber mit etwas
honig servieren mit warnung honig das
habe ich in der türkei auch schon
gegessen
also man hat einfach die option entweder
mit sirup tränken oder damit honig
servieren und ich will es die option mit
honig
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr vor dem
servieren noch etwas glitter schnee
darüber geben
das könnt ihr direkt mit puderzucker
drauf geben denn der gc bleibt bleibt
immer schön auf der oberfläche und
schmilzt nicht und ich finde da durch
sieht einfach noch mal ein bisschen
hübscher aus pistazien habe ich jetzt
hier auch gehackte noch mit drauf
gegeben und zum servieren nehme ich
jetzt süß millionen also sahnejoghurt
dem stichfesten zehnprozentigen gar die
sahne joghurt mit nämlich hervorragend
dazu kaymak also haben würde auch passen
aber ich finde dann wird es zu schwer
lieber joghurt dazu und warmen honig
rosie methode abschnitts probieren und
darf mir mal sagen wie es dir schmeckt
okay die gleiche wirkung mit dem
stichfesten joghurt kann man drauf
gesetzt
es ist so kriegt man es in der türkei
auch serviert und dann warmen honig
darüber fließen lassen
[Musik]
nortel steckt habe ich schon für dich
kennt stuttgart will das gibt es beim
griechen aber das ist sally bercow novak
djokovic und im prinzip innen nur der
pudding süß und dann braucht halt den
honig sei dazu für den teig ist jetzt
gilt es aber das ist ja so gut dass
gleich zur die süße auch aus ja man muss
eigentlich mit gabel und messer essen
tut mir leid ich habe jetzt nur einer
gabel gegeben und ich weiß gar nicht was
ich besser findet wird es besser finden
mit sirup gedrängt oder so mit dem honig
gern weil dann kann man auch selber
bestimmen wie süß man es haben möchte
und es bleibt halt auch die ganze zeit
über so knackig und dann gibt man den
honig drauf und dann unterboden der und
loszulegen
ach so ich muss dazu sagen jetzt 40
einzelne schichten ausgerollt ganz
schöne plätze ganz allein das tun aber
ich weiß noch gestalten genießer dass
sie mir genießt mein essen menschen bei
mohammed ist schon längst aufgegessen
also wenn ihr möchtet und eure familie
oder eure freunde mit diesem dessert
überraschen möchte dann probiert gerne
mal aus wie gesagt entweder mit der
selbstgemachten tag variante oder die
gekaufte die geht noch schneller
schreibt es mir gerne in die kommentare
und postet ein foto und schreibt mir
auch gerne mal wie es euch am besten
schmeckt mit zuckersirup oder mit honig
und vielleicht auch ob es dieses gericht
auch bei euch im land oder aus dem
ursprungsland gibt wie gesagt in
griechenland heißt ballack trikot in der
türkei laufen und wahrscheinlich gibt es
auch noch in anderen regionen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen guten appetit und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]